but i really wish somebody had
made it known to me that like you don't
necessarily have to be
quentin tarantino to make a living
making movies
what's the one thing you wish someone
had
had a heart-to-heart talk with you and
said this is what's going to happen and
this where it's going to be hard
and you learned it on your own and
i i wish that someone had set me down
and been more
um like realistic in your expectations
of what your career is going to be you
know or what it takes to make a living
as a filmmaker so when i was starting
out i had the same
you know the same vision that most
filmmakers do like you know i'm gonna
make this low-budget movie and i'm gonna
put it in film festivals and it's gonna
get discovered and some big distributors
gonna pick it up and it's just gonna
it's gonna take off and i'm gonna be
spike lee or i'm gonna be quentin
tarantino or i'm gonna be robert
rodriguez
and and that's what it takes to be able
to make a living doing movies but but
it's it's not so you know there's a
whole like sub level of working class
filmmakers that are making movies that a
lot of people would consider backyard
movies movies shot for ten thousand
dollars or twenty thousand dollars or
thirty thousand dollars and there are
people out there that are making these
movies and can make livings off of them
you know you might not be rich i'm not
on red carpets and you know i'm not
getting oscars and awards and all of
that
but
i'm doing what i love to do and i'm
making a living at it and to be really
honest and a lot of people will say that
i'm uh you know i'm um rationalizing it
um because i'm not at the higher level
but honestly at this point in my career
like i don't want to be much higher i
mean don't get me wrong if you know if i
you know stumbled on a 500 000 budget as
opposed to a 50 that'd be great i'd love
to do that but as far as like directing
you know like studio films or tentpole
stuff i have absolutely no desire to do
that any anymore you know i
did when i started but not now but i
really wish somebody had
made it known to me that like you don't
necessarily have to be
quentin tarantino to make a living
making movies
it's interesting how
people's desires for success change and
maybe you get tastes of it here and you
realize you know what this is a lot of
stress over here i kind of like this
realm where i'm doing my own thing i'm
still accountable but
i don't have to be you know
there's a price to pay i think for
certain levels of a career yeah yeah
totally and one thing that's always been
a
not a problem but a you know a source of
anxiety for me especially when i have
outside investors like
you know i feel you know you know a
moral and you know and of course a you
know legal responsibility to return
the money and when you're making movies
for fifty thousand dollars or sixty
thousand dollars or twenty thousand
dollars
most of the people that are investing in
those movies are not super rich people
you know because like real like you know
rich you know experienced investors
they're not going to invest in a 60 000
movie you know and not because it can't
be profitable but because
you know there's a ceiling to how
profitable it can be
you know like yes sky is the limit but
you know it's outliers you know for the
most part if you do a hundred movies at
50 000 the most one of those is going to
make in a year
in general terms is you know like maybe
a couple hundred thousand and that's
like at the tippity top so for a you
know a regular investor somebody that
you know invests millions of dollars or
you know they have big they're that's
just not an exciting investment they're
like what i'm going to put 60 000 and
you know two years later i'm gonna get
150 back or you know maybe 200 it's just
not
you know so it's
so the people that are investing in
these movies are usually
you know people like myself you know
that you know we're we're making modest
livings we have a good year we might
have 10 or 15 that we can throw towards
something and we do
you know and but so then as a filmmaker
when you get that money
you have all this you want to be able to
return it you know one of my movies i
produced back in 2010 and it was a i
think a 35 000 budget and one of the
producers who i'd worked with for years
um he had it it's finally our project to
work together and he had come into some
like family money a family member had
passed or something like that so he had
a little bit of a nest egg and you know
he ended up putting like fifteen
thousand dollars into that movie
so
eventually the movie made its money back
but it took a long time and and i felt
that every day until that money was
returned
that's just how i like like me as a
filmmaker i can't take money and then
not return it and feel okay you know and
i'm still my last narrative film which i
know my tagline is i make movies that
make money but my last narrative film
the campus death day it was a financial
failure it didn't make its budget back
and
there was you know quite a few like two
and three thousand dollar investors in
that that you know they could really use
that money and they never made it and i
you know i'll always feel bad about that
was there a moment jay when the
hollywood dream was no more you just
wanted to be a working-class filmmaker
or a middle-class filmmaker
i would say i would say it pro like
maybe around five years ago it started
to occur to me that hey you know maybe
like i'm not gonna be directing million
dollar movies you know but but i still i
still kind of hold on to it you know
still like that like that's the goal but
somewhere in the last like two years
like moving out to georgia and doing the
documentaries full-time and and honestly
doing my my youtube channel like
i just i just realized that you know i
don't i really don't even desire that
anymore i like i don't desire the red
carpet stuff anymore or you know the
adulation of millions or you know
whatever it is it's just it really
became about the work and what i think
what really changed for me
for the better and i recommend this for
like all filmmakers
when you stop
making movies a hundred percent for
yourself
and start making them for others
is when things change you know at least
it did for me when i stopped thinking
about my little precious passion project
and i start thinking about
like you know with the documentaries for
example i'm making a dog rescue
documentary and i'm bringing awareness
to you know this issue and this this
small little dog rescue that might be
struggling like
that's what making that movie was about
you know and then a byproduct of that
it can be financially successful you
know or even you know i'm getting ready
to do uh a horror movie craving my first
narrative in a few years and but totally
this isn't just like hey this is my
script that i wanted to make you know
the whole time i'm like
what is the sub genre what is the
audience expecting from the sub genre
what can i give them to make this better
you know and and i think that that leads
to
you know more
practical success
you had been in la how many years 15 15.
so you came here from georgia
um
now uh when you came out here too okay
so
originally i was from indiana i grew up
in indiana um and it didn't really seem
like
uh you know i was really into movies
like i was a small kid i you know didn't
really play sports i just watched movies
so
but there was no
like it didn't seem like that was a real
thing that you could do
you know like i was shooting little
videos and stuff but it never crossed my
mind you know before i moved out of
indiana that
movies are something that i could do and
make some money at you know it's like
you had to be in los angeles or new york
or you had to be you know just famous
and discovered
and
i moved from indiana to louisiana i
worked offshore for about a year and a
half save some money for college and
then decided i was going to go to school
and the university of new orleans had a
pretty good film program and so i went
there i studied communications and film
and
this was right around the time that
panasonic released their dvx uh 100 the
24p mini dv camera
yeah and uh
all of a sudden and in like uh what is
it 28 days later it'd come out and i was
like oh it's like it's suddenly feasible
to like shoot a feature film and so i
started thinking more about it as like a
practical career and that right after i
graduated college that summer you know
we pulled together a few thousand
dollars and that's when we shot rise of
the undead which was my first movie